Could you please clearly explain what you mean? That's
irresistible evidence.
It's an unscrupulous act that extorts money from customers by telling them about the mountain's cuisine, which is popular on the street. Yes, that's
right. They slapped someone in prison and said that mountain's cuisine was fake.  The
reason for this is that I
thought I could get away with saying that,
so I brought this person with me.He is Marcelsis, the best cook in the mountains, the
disciple and guru of the Liner try-on.
[Music] Come on,
Mr. Marcel,
testimony.  You
won't know for sure until you
try it, right?
Anyway, let's have some food. Well then, I'd like some soup, omelet rice, and a
hamburger.
This is a dish that Marchel doesn't know about, so it's definitely a fake.
Wait.
[Music]
Who made this dish?
Now this restaurant is also making a fuss about us parents and children. It's so noisy. What on earth is
this?
[Music]
So why are you telling me this dish that you haven't taught me?  Are
you talking?
[Music]
Is it the legendary mountain cuisine, the legendary girl?